huge tour announcement calling on all
the army of garbage we just added a
bunch of dates to the state tracking
door for the fall and for the winter
stand-up comedy show plus we play a
little ayg with the crowd great way to
introduce new people to the show come
out and see the boys yeah gang all
tickets are available at our website Ru
garbage.com uh we're coming to Phoenix
Denver Salt Lake City Los Angeles San
Diego Washington D.C Pittsburgh Buffalo
Toronto Pontiac Michigan Chicago
Minneapolis Madison Milwaukee Sacramento
San Francisco San Jose and then we're
ending it in Philadelphia Pennsylvania
maybe get those tickets let's party
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage hey it's that little
shall we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find that if they're
good to be classy yeah or to just a big
old piece of trash trash I'm your host
Dave trolley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here with
hoodies in the new edition she was just
stocking up the garage grids with freeze
pops okay tell me I look like I work at
Best Buy hey shout out to The Geek Squad
huh a couple of zingers coming my way
she can be a cruel lady when she wants
to be sure my Carlos is coming at you
from across the table this is a family
episode just to bozos the homies and the
boys that's what we do just the way we
like it sometimes give it up for KJ
Kevin James Ryan everybody what up gang
thanks for tuning in and as always
please make sure you rate view subscribe
on iTunes full video available on
YouTube as you know those numbers are
Thriller out cooking and obviously the
greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage gang you
sign up over there we're almost at ten
thousand patrons baby keeping me in
those epic it's goddamn [__]
homieville over there baby ten dollar
homies all around check it out gang get
a [__] ton of bonus content the Indie
videos up there oh my goodness and
having a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire speaking of the
Indie video the brains behind the
operation he's the magic man makes us
all look good looks real good in one of
them racing suits too I'll tell you that
give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby
McMullen everybody what up boys hey pal
I'm going straight one piece from here
on out I told you that it's the only
article of clothing that looks good on
me I think I wouldn't make funny as much
I'd treat you in a little more respect
if you were walking around cool guy in
with that thing I get it unless I can
light you on fire and you'll be okay
just fall through the table oh dude you
have a lot of fun fireworks those things
yeah dude uh and also shout out to new
guy Luke with the angles all over that
Indie video sure crushing it sure sure
good kid like Luke good kid but not cool
like you I'll tell you that right now in
that in that jumper you could just wear
those you know that right no he can no
one can just first of all they're about
[__] 300 degrees in them things no
one can just wear them all right no but
just the regular ones like the ones like
if you were working at a garage like a
Michael Myers yeah sure that I'm Michael
Myers yeah no that ain't great he's
gonna talk about creeping out the girls
at the party
Hey where's will your serial killer
friend stop staring at me
why does he keep want to go hang out at
the lake what's this guy's deal
he won't shut up about the train tracks
I don't know what's going on yeah we get
it she was your babysitter all right get
over it she don't like you no more hey
Blair Witch zip it will you
try to get laid over here dude
I could go do a lap or something this
guy talking about his mommy issues on
Halloween she's dead man get over it
have a Clark Bar dude it's all good I
got a I got something I want to get into
I was just down there with the family
this weekend oh yeah down there with the
boys hanging out brother did a nice
barbecue nice not that sweet spot down
there he's got it he's got his Tony
Soprano backyard it's fantastic got the
pull The Hardscape that is to that is it
a coincidence that both of our brothers
are better than us yeah that's why we
met up okay to plot their demise I had
to take them down from this one get a
little piece just want a hamburger what
are we doing
couple of dogs for the boys if I could
move in with them if they if they had
enough my brothers
what
Fantasy Camp are you in I would love
that no no you're with just a successful
guy no my brother if I could move in
with them in the fam I'd be okay with
that have a little room up there that
wouldn't end well no of course not we
already tried that in the early two
seconds I tried it and you didn't pay
rent
uh no it was nice it's good The Burbs
are nice big fan of The Burbs as I get
older slow down couple of heaters out
back whatever had all the kids over a
bunch of my this is what I wanted to
talk about I've realized obviously after
doing this show and then spending time
so much time with my family like this
has made me re-evaluate how I look at my
upbringing in my family how trashy you
exactly were and are yeah and my family
yes exactly sure just you know even if
there it doesn't go away no it was just
the 80s and the 90s it was like this fog
that you couldn't really see through
because you didn't really know what
other people were doing there was no no
internet back then yeah shout out to Al
Gore
um so we're there we're all hanging out
right pops are everything's hanging it's
good and good coolers what do you got
yetis doing yetis down there no he's got
the fridge he's got the with the fridge
outside got an outside fridge wait what
do you mean I don't know I'll still
explain it really yeah you don't got to
go you didn't need any backup
information on that no okay you don't
have to walk down to things and go into
the garage and get one it's right there
got a fridge outside really soft to the
brim real get a brim you open it there's
Coors Lights falling out it's like a
Goddamn treasure chest for an alcoholic
get off me high Dunes
uh yeah so we're there hanging out you
know it's a it's a whole thing and so
one of my cousins shows up he was just
at a soccer game he's drunk he was
coaching he's at a something he's in a
game right so like now everybody starts
coming together can I say this I don't
mean to interject sure that's the show
um say something uh all I can speak from
is the the Greater Philadelphia Suburban
area because that's all I really know
but that was nine different accents
hello yarn me suburbs
hey Dad here Philly mate
um man I've been speaking of which I was
an interview with Rod Stewart he's got
something going on that guy is a
treasure Trove of a [__] just
awesomeness yeah I could sit and listen
to him talk for days hey we bought the
house he's a dirty football player too
by the way shout out to my cousin Kevin
he came in cleats up on him
thought it was a [__] friendly anyway
yeah
the soccer lacrosse field hockey uh
youth leagues that they got down there
have really oh it's on steroids it's
private this club that I mean over by my
mom they have these I used to play
soccer on a [__] baseball field now
it's like they got bleachers there's an
owner's box it's like what the [__] are
we doing here yeah I'm out there like
the [__] Raiders and [__] 75. I
didn't I remember being a little kid and
seeing that and being like what the [__]
is a catch a punt in the shadow I'm like
what is up with this team man you can't
get your own spot
[__] with me get a co-signer or
something it was brutal talk about
staying at your brother's place you need
to help me you know how bad it is for
your knees to go from astro turf to
[__] dirt in two steps I remember
being a kid watching that being like
what in the [__] this ain't flisses I
can't remember what this is the deal was
this is like the longest yard dude the
Raiders played I guess it would have
been at uh at the days no oh yeah it
wasn't the oak I'm guessing I was
[__] two when this was happening I
was thinking candlestick
no isn't that San Francisco yeah that's
what I was thinking Oakland San
Francisco I don't know I I don't know
um but so anyway they got a big
operation down there yeah it's a thing
and the you know uh so they come in and
one of the one of the little kids uh
uh gotten have gotten a fist fight
really got in a fist fight with two or
three other kids ran up on them what
during the game I think it was after it
was after the game and I think it was
holy [__] yeah and he [__] pieced
them up too sweet he comes from good
stock this is so he's a soccer player
he's a soccer soccer kids going after
each other after the game you guys
they're usually flopping no but this is
this is what I'm realizing they're all
floppers right it's like no the first
the first group it's Philly Dirtbag and
then soccer player so at the end of the
day gotcha they're still ready to throw
some fisticuffs gotcha this kid's six
something young little kid little kid
comes in and peace apparently peace
these two tree kids up too sweet yeah
but they jumped them by The Cars
apparently and he's got he's got good
genes this kid comes from uh comes from
a big guy huh so [__]
you know hit him with the [__] you
know the the old [__] one two selling
candy anybody see any uh yeah his dad
saw yeah but he [__] got some into it
any heat any any any uh what
ramifications apparently on the lamb in
another school district that's what I'm
saying no no no and then the the kids
because they can get real prissy about
that [__] no it's like the kids parents
can't they like they were in the wrong
for sure okay with the kids you know uh
but I think he's a bigger kid so they
were like let's try to get him or
whatever and they didn't so the South
were the boys the other kids parents
were like oh hey sorry I think I I think
I don't know that's nice hey sorry my
kids try to jump yours but that's nice
well they still go get a hot dog when
the parents start acting like idiots
then then it's a [__] that's not
completely disqualified from my family
either right really yeah why are you
gonna have to get in we don't have to
get into two three things but we're
moving talking about the kids
but they came in and
my my cousin told the story he's like oh
you know so-and-so got in a fight and it
was like that scene from Goodfellas that
he popped his Cherry all the uncles were
like yeah you [__] them up I'm like god
dude we are some [__] Dirtbag
normally you'd be like hey don't
violence isn't the answer don't hit them
they were like you [__] got him dude
what happened give me give him a sippy
cup of Coors Light and a medium rare
Burger
I was like gotta have your steak rare
now I was sitting there I'm like this
kid this is crazy but then I started
thinking like that's how we were raised
it was like you know probably kept your
mouth shut they didn't want to [__]
tuning you up huh straightening you out
but it's just like almost like holy New
York softy over here oh you popped your
cherry they were like carrying around he
was the belle of the ball after they
found out he [__] you know sure he
gave someone the two-piece
I was like Jesus Christ shout out to it
baby couple of kids laying next to an
old Corvette
here hide this gun
I knew I was in trouble at that point
but I couldn't look away
he's got a chick with him
hey this is Karen by the way
ah yeah it was just a really big look
into the psyche of my family and I was
just like damn and it made me feel nice
because that's who we all answer you're
gonna say you got put store-bought
potato salad
no we haven't we have enough violence we
have an elementary school fight club
going on if you want to get your nephews
in how was the grub Rob was good who's
working that Grill because it is summer
it is grilling season yeah now he did
he's got the the Blackstone the big uh
the Big John yeah he's got a great
[__] son does he have a griddle too a
flat top on that thing I think it's a
whole flat top really yeah so everything
was done on the flat top I think really
yeah that's what they're doing these
days it's like it's my dream I know
you're a Smash Burger kid oh and the
breakfast you can whip up on those
things man those are unparalleled with
the size of your head what are you
talking about I used to love watching
them at College uh our cafeteria they
had a huge flat top and you could watch
any real lady killer huh you want to go
see him make eggs I mean you've never
seen hash browns so crispy I tell you if
we get there early you can watch them
flip the burgers
no
man between that and your engineering
Fred they uh shout out to Theta kai no
they were dead they had a big flat top
and there was the first time I saw them
all like spread out and folded up real
nice pretty cool sure yeah yeah but I
have to say this summertime grilling
that flat top [__] get come on it's all
about the Open Flame I don't disag I
mean chore I guess if you wanna that's
not grilling that's griddling
I'd say you're working at some greasy
spoon on the highway I mean this [__]
you need like a Traeger or something
like that
or a grill you need both sure you need
both I think he's got a grill I just
think for this he has to yeah of course
I think the size of it I mean there was
40 people there okay so it's like that
griddle it's a big he's got orders
coming in it's yeah he's [__] jammed
up talking about in the weeds the rush
86 the cheese dogs
really nah no no cheese dogs
you don't see them that much anymore no
unless not unless you're at the niece's
house does she still get them yeah she
knows she knows the weight of my heart
the Oscar Meyer the original on some
potato roll if I'm coming down yeah yeah
you don't really see them on the uh on
the grill nah that's a microwave that's
a you're eating those by yourself I
think however I don't grill right there
is a company it turns chemically there's
an operation out of um
I want to say Wisconsin can you give me
a Google on this you singers
you singers
I want to say it's Wisconsin okay and
what about it they do they ship all over
the country I think and my old man
according to my research my old man had
them uh had them send them a little
something one summer and one of the
things they sent were these with these
uh cheese hot dogs like like real good
cheese Hot Dogs
man you singers famous sausage dude yeah
Milwaukee Wisconsin Milwaukee Wisconsin
you are a [__] a pork byproduct
Savant that's crazy you just nailed that
have you ever been to Milwaukee no
how about you just know this is fat
[__] eyeing up that box
like we're like you're reading the back
of a [__] cereal box when you're
eating I'm doing a maze
poor poor snout oof delicious yeah so
yeah we should bring that back what the
cheese dog should be more
in in the adult grilling
genre how about that does that make
sense this summer we could do it we
could turn it around yeah you act like
we could we're trying to start a slow
clap here I'm going home this weekend
cheese dogs on the grill that's it I
don't even have to add one
take a walk around will you
okay can I say something might be
controversial cheese dog she's in the
dog fantastic but but any sort of melted
cheese on the hot dog
except I'm well documented on this
program
the text is Tommy from high school
sure was was unbelievable I I listen I
don't know if you did them I love
a deli slot the crafting I love a deli
slice piece of [__] white American
cheese on a diesel underneath it now
they look like cut it and like you you
break it in half and put it it's it's
not all the time it's not my go-to but
it's [__] it's all right a little
dabble do you not a hot dog duck on this
show I'll tell you that we're two fat
[__] idiots
and Italian famous sausage
we're not just dog guys too speaking of
which Patty did get some uh some little
sausages I want to say uh via Veneta
someplace down here uh East Norton man
I don't even need the coffee I'm saying
snap wake up hear that snap from across
the river god damn it's not like a tree
breaking
uh good stuff yeah but all the hot dog
is Hot Dog Talk aside yes we got a
goddamn we got business to do here it's
a goddamn broadcast it's a program we
got garbage to get into baby it's a
family up so when you sign up for
patreon we will answer your garbage
question on the air and like we've said
one two three million times that's the
greatest website of all time we got more
content on that goddamn website than you
all believe it's true blow your [__]
hair back when you get on it knock your
compression socks off over there
um all right let's see here this is from
my wife's boyfriend is it garbage to get
a rental car as a gift my mom always
wanted a convertible so one year my dad
rented one for her birthday oh man talk
about oh [__] you'd have to really
gingerly approach that now listen
there's something outside for you but
it's going back Monday and you got to
make sure the tank filled up
and then we got to cover the tolls which
by the way I like that Flex that that
you do on the road with uh with with the
rental car
you pay you pay the thing up front where
you don't got to fill the tank up that's
because [__] them yeah but you're paying
you're prepaying the gas that's it's in
their best interest but the problem is
I'm a forgetful Frank you always yeah
dude you always forget then you're
worried about it is it going to be a
little bit under that's why I'm buying
piece of my I'm just buying yeah [__]
and then I do realize I'm like oh we got
to get to the airport in the morning and
we're like you know we're scraping that
we're running on fumes sure I'll go
throw five six bucks in there just to
get me there and then you're returning
really Jam them yeah hey buddy you might
have to throw this thing in neutral
coming out of the garage
good luck figure but that's tough too
because I think it's a gift if you have
a rental car I I mean a convertible
that's just such a generic thing it'd be
one thing if you're like I rented yet
1955 Chevy T-top whatever like something
exotic and like a classic car but just
you just going to get like Sebring Vibes
sure that's what I'm saying they don't
you know they don't have may boxing [__]
you can rent those apps that have all of
that crazy cars I don't think that's I
don't think this guy was doing that yeah
no and it's also you have to have a
destination and I saw something with
cigarette Burns in it they were here
when I got them for sure I think you
should have this shouldn't be the gift
hey get in we'll ride around town it
should be I'm taking your your favorite
dinner and then you'll walk out and
you're like hop in a convertible that's
nice you gotta go somewhere it can't
just be cruise around now get to the
grocery store
I feel that feel that wind in your hair
and grab some cheese dogs for the boys
happy birthday you're ready to watch me
drive I know you said you wanted to go
to Home Depot so uh there you go you're
not an authorized driver you got to be
in the passengers it's pretty trashy the
um the the fascination with the
convertible itself I think what was the
last time you were in one
uh I was in one in um in Hawaii when we
were over there ah
actually what am I talking about I did a
pretty trashy thing I rented a BMW
convertible was whipping around in that
thing over there could not fit in this
car it was a [__] project
every time
and once I got in there I was in there
there was no popping out for anything
dude it was [__] brutal you have to
take the steering wheel off like it's a
race car
dude it sucked but when you're but
that's a little bit different you're on
the H3 out there [__] heading over to
the [__] other side of the island the
wind's whipping through your air I get
it but there is an over
um
I don't know sure it's yeah no I don't
like it that great now that wait you're
also crammed in one you're not comfy
you're not you're not [__] sitting
pretty also too when the hood when the
thing's not down you feel like you're
you're driving around in a baseball hat
yeah it feels like a cigarette boat when
you're in there no good it's it's like a
tent dude yeah it's a low hanging yeah
and the bat in the back windshield is
not glass it's like plastic
what are people making attempts at your
life were you worried about a [__]
Sharpshooter [__] taking you out
uh yeah I mean I I don't know I whoa I
didn't know you did that that's crazy
that's real that's like [__] it was
just like SoundCloud rapper [__] renting
a cool car to look cool and I didn't
film a video you got a drone if you got
the bird on the hood
all right what's up y'all I'm stuck
you know how we live in okay let's talk
about that indochino baby Indochina
wedding season is upon us you ain't
lying I got one next week weddings can
be fun but they could also be
expensive expensive you got the gifts
you got the hotel stay you got the
babysitter plus you got to pick a little
something up for the wedding you know
what I mean hey have a good time there
sure you get a little pricey you know
I'm talking about T-Bone Indochina will
give you the perfect look at an awesome
price customize every detail of your
suit shirt dinner jacket and more for an
outfit you'll love to wear over and over
and over again yeah gang uh if you're a
bigger bigger guy like us hey you can't
buy off buying off the rack you'll look
like you're you belong in a in a goddamn
Cedar box
you look like you belong in the
obituaries it's a bad look but they they
tailor it for your your big shoulders if
you got a big belly if you got a set of
man boobs whatever it is they take care
of you indochino even has tuxedo
starting at just 500 seven nine dollars
instead of good I know instead of
running a [__] mediocre suit for 300
I know you can customize your own tux
perfectly fit your body and style to
really up your wardrobe game check out
endocino's custom fitted shirts and
Casual Wear you could be killing a game
all over the place there you go uh so
it's easy to stay on Trend and in style
RSVP knowing you got the perfect looked
all wedding season uh all wedding season
long from indochino go to indochino.com
and use code garbage to get 10 off any
purchase of 399 or more that's indochino
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o.com promo code garbage
indochino.com code garbage do it gang
yeah close some ass out there okay let's
talk about expressvpn you mean someone
who's got your Goddamn back in this data
this data world let's talk about closing
the blinds when you're doing your
business you know what I mean gang
Netflix has tens of thousands of shows
but depending on your location sure can
you get them can you this can you that
this is blacked out this is not blacked
out in 2023 we're not in our Blockbuster
anymore gang it shows the movies
available only in your city and who
needs that do yourself a favor
expressvpn lets you do just whatever you
want to do with 100 different server
locations you can access thousands of
new shows uh yeah for sure I was I never
really thought it was important and then
they gave us they gave us a hookup I got
it and it's not even for like I don't
want the government to know what I'm
doing which is good they shouldn't know
what you're doing what you're perusing
it's also it blocks off of selling your
data all these advertisers who's getting
what buying this selling that nah not
what expressvpn they got your back fatal
trap baby uh it's compatible on all your
devices so you can watch all your
favorite shows on your phone laptop
Tablet Smart TV surf Turf whatever you
want baby with blazing fast speeds you
can stream with zero buffering and
expressvpn even encrypt your data so you
can browse the web securely baby that's
what it's all about so be smart stop
paying full price for streaming service
person and only getting access to a
fraction of their content get your
money's worth at expressvpn.com garbage
don't forget to use our Link at
expressvpn.com garbage to get an extra
three months free of expressvpn we don't
need something free expressvpn
expressvpn.com garbage can do it now
back to the gosh Dawn show back to the
show I didn't tell you that I don't
think so yeah it was the same was it
wasn't even that much more than whatever
the other one was
which I don't know what that means but
still sure
whenever I've been in a convertible I
always feel like oh this flips were just
smooshed well technically no the
windshield like yes yeah dude but also
like how often are cars flipping it's
not like you've been in five cars that
have flipped I drive like the wind baby
no you you are the worst driver in the
world that has to have been a question
have you or anyone in your family been
inverted in their car sure man I
remember one time I was on 95 and did
you ever just like see something I'm
like I've driven a lot and this car was
maybe 15 feet in the air hanging in a
tree and the guy's like I'm all right
I'm like what the [__] are you doing how
did that happen
he was in the car yeah like it was like
stop you know did you ever see like you
like
like jackass or like jump in the tree
like you know they don't get all the way
down because like all the branches
support do this dude was just to the
wheels are spinning Jesus yeah I'm like
oh would you hit a kick kicker or
something what's going on here that when
cars are on fire how does that happen
they [__] play they explode it's like
are you grilling in the car there's a
couple of spots on the Jersey Turnpike
where I don't yeah dude it looks like it
looks like burning man was there yeah
dude clean that the [__] up will you
it's not good somebody get that Mr Clean
thing out there you can see the Flesh on
the side of the road dude I don't need
to drive by that [__] that's crazy they
used to do a really good job on the
Jersey Turnpike now it's all jammed up a
lot of construction there's a lot of
[__] like that get a crew out there I
don't want to [__] drive by that [__]
and think about that poor son of a [__]
I'm stuck in my car yeah dude
well I can't get out of my car take it
out of my convertible it's in a parallel
park and you're paralyzed parking
it sucked and I felt like uh I felt like
a [__] uh like a Star Wars toy inside
the uh X-Wing like my legs were just
completely Straight Like That dude it
sucked right down there on the floor
having to move it all the way down get
it in there plus with the valet at the
hotel I'm taking like 10 minutes to get
in the car it's [__] embarrassing
girl but I told you that your girl must
have been slipping out of her seat right
a real hunk like you babe put it in put
it in park put it Jesus
laughs
[__] move that guy shifter's under my
leg the shifter's under my leg uh I will
say that Porsche pretty classy I think
the trashiest convertible of all time is
the Miata
I don't know yeah it took a lot of heat
when it came out I remember when those
things dropped for about two weeks they
were cool and then everybody turned on
them I don't think like hyenas yeah for
about two weeks people thought they were
cool and then I don't know a lot of art
teachers started buying them stuff like
that how look you look let's see what we
can get a Miata for uh new one yeah I
don't they're not making them new yeah
what this is this guy just
they got 2023 at Mazda Miatas real way
yes what's a sticker on that uh what do
they look like they kind of look like
Porsches
Mazda Miata no kidding they must have
brought them back they were they haven't
been going Full Tilt since the 90s
starting at twenty eight thousand
dollars or 0.9 APR they kind of do look
like Porsches let me see he's not wrong
the long hair ain't lying folks it's
much better than the old ones I'll tell
you that much we'll get a pick up there
let me see let me take a little peek
trying bud I'm trying yeah but I feel
like every everybody they modeled around
this car was real short in real life all
the angles are like real low that's not
a big guy car
uh I wouldn't say it looks like a porch
it looks like one of those uh BMWs yeah
a little bit I'm saying it don't look
like a Miata that you know it don't look
good it's small yeah it don't look like
the that's for unsuccessful dentists to
drive around then I think for divorced
unsuccessful dentists the mid-range
practice yes maybe attached to the house
yeah or he works at another dentist's
office yeah he doesn't have his own spot
yeah this is Dr so-and-so he's new yeah
he was working out in Hershey for a
little while that's where he's doing his
open mics where he cut his cut his teeth
uh yeah that's not a that's not a real
wild call you can't pull up in a Miata
no you'd be you'll catch some [__]
[__] for sure
uh all right let's see here this one's
from James ten dollar Long Island trash
here are you garbage if towards the end
of your parents marriage your dad took
over your twin bread your twin bed and
you had to sleep on the floor
damn oh my God that is a tough look I
was like our buddy Brendan that's very
saggle o-esque yeah shout out to be sags
I mean at some point he had to move into
the den took his room
economically why make it worse on
everybody listen it's not working out
let's keep it in the family we're not
fighting whatever
I guess I don't know we only have a two
bedroom
hey the old man's gonna be staying with
you it's probably the best time of his
life I think you know as a dad I think
you got to get the couch no sure and
kind of put up a little curtain be like
this is my hat this is my room over here
one side Junior me and your mom are
beefing yes something kick your kid out
on a goddamn floor he's got school in
the morning the [__]
she's trying to get lazy he's trying to
[__] you know he's bringing the
chicks back he's trying to get the
second base with a broad and [__]
he's got no confidence he's sleeping on
the floor
yeah it's pretty trashy man I'm so glad
that didn't happen with me I'm so glad
it was a easy
out there's a little extra cash
sure well not really we went to he went
to a motel
sure
so it wasn't like yeah it was nothing I
mean he's not like Tony Soprano I'm
gonna be at the Waldorf wherever the
[__] he wanted a plaza yeah [__] I'd be
getting divorced too if I could do that
[__] go State the plaza for an
indefinite time get hookers in there
still and holy walnuts coming by yeah
what the [__] and some chicks
you know
yeah eating those big turbolones
[Music]
always comes back to you I just watched
that I get divorced for chocolate unless
I get my own toblerones in a hotel room
you ain't gotta tell me nothing I just
watched the episode uh all right let's
see this is from Dave at 10 bozo is it
garbage to apply Sun spray sunscreen in
the house before going out it's funny I
didn't think so but in Indy Pat did it
yeah well you guys all were going
outside and I was like oh [__] and then
I did it then I almost broke my neck I
know man you do it on the wrong you do
it on a cheap wood floor you're going
down yeah hey that's a [__] that's
like quicksand for the if somebody
doesn't know yeah and then they make a
pivot on it yeah I'll tell you what that
stuff works pretty good
sure and you know but I can't remember
it was either you or new guy Luke what
he's was like I said get my neck and you
were [__] right up on it you got to
step back with that and spray nice that
was me and let me ask you something is
your neck burn no but I had blue I had
Luke redo it
I don't want to have spots all over me
no you rub it in you rub it in you don't
rub it in yes you do why am I rubbing it
in when it's got the spray I'll rub them
to make sure it's evenly done it is
evenly done you do it nice with the
spray that's how you miss things I'm
telling you okay I'm telling you check
the instructions it probably doesn't say
rub it in well I all I did was spray and
I didn't get burned once out there I
rubbed that got a nice collar once huh I
robbed it I didn't get burnt once well
and it's and it recommends which is
something I've never done my entire life
until this trip was you're supposed to
apply it in the shade and wait like 15
minutes that's nuts who's doing that now
yeah you're you're jammed I'm not
sitting under the [__] tree for 15
minutes but that's the same [__] as
don't eat a half hour before you go into
the water which can I say this you've
never been in a pool huh which means
you've never been in a pool
there hasn't been a half hour since
you've eaten oh we got it oh I don't
think you did I I know when you don't
get a joke and I see you doing the math
in your head
um
this might be more hard feelings but so
you know we're going down the shore
I apologize but there is a big down the
shore most houses have a no sunscreen in
the house rule for that reason do it in
the garage do that you do that [__] at
Denise's house down there in North
Wildwood she'll lose it [__] bounced
that guy ain't allowed back no kidding
yeah maybe a couple passive aggressive
marks what's all slippery on this floor
and you're [__] mum's the word she's
[__] digging at you but anyway we're
going down there we're going down to
Wildwood yes in the middle of the summer
um
there's been unless I'm crazy
it seems like there's something really
going on in the ocean lately
there's been a lot of [__] start this
and then you're never gonna go in the
ocean don't be that guy I mean dude the
poor [__] Russian guy in [__]
Egypt that was crazy in Egypt the [__]
it's Gotta what's that got to do in
North Wildwood the kid that jumped off
the the cruise ship
and then it was a video of you jumping
off a cruise ship anytime soon there was
a video then then there was the kayaker
in Hawaii where a tiger shark just came
right up to it and tried to take a bite
out of them and then for some reason I
saw a video yesterday there was all
these Dolphins trying to beach
themselves like a whole [__] bunch of
them somebody was probably grilling some
cheese dogs
it would have missed out he's cooking
yeah he is [__] beaching them it
seems there's something uh yeah I guess
I mean you named Egypt the Baha a guy
who jumped off a boat I think that's in
Hawaii I think that shows that it's all
over that would be like me if I was like
it was like a volcano went off a hundred
years ago like if you just look at all
the bad things that are happening
constantly they're always bad how many
people went in the water and didn't get
bit this week I don't know couple
hundred million I don't know for sure
seems a little a little fishy all right
then I got a line on proper spray suntan
usage hit me you gotta rub it in one way
to ensure staying protected is spray
spray close to the skin to ensure
accurate coverage with the spray
sunscreen I highly recommend holding the
nozzle to your skin and spraying
thoroughly boom I was helping you out
yeah [__] burn and turn baby Freeze
It Up
uh I like that stuff yeah but you can't
do that [__] in the house that is that
is a no-fly because it's just in the air
it's on the ground it's on the table
it's on the chair sure you're you're
walking through it the dog's looking at
it gets on the lunch meat yeah although
it does kind of taste good in a weird
way yeah like lip gloss and it highly
recommends you apply It Outdoors to
avoid inhaling any of the particles yeah
that's half the fun the the accelerants
or whatever they use
that's not good for you which is weird
because they slow your brain down take
my chance
[Music]
this one's from Foley guacamole ten
dollar homie are you garbage if you have
had a Coors Light in a hospital room
you shouldn't be drinking in a hospital
at all let alone I don't care what kind
of brain uh somebody had a baby
celebrating or somebody's on their way
out you want to have a little louder
okay this made it seem like he's killing
time
he didn't give an event like hey it was
you know my pop-up was on his way out
and we all shotgun the beer before he
[__] before he [__] entered
Sandman you know what I mean I was
picturing a white styrofoam coffee cup
yeah I was picturing like chill the
nurse is coming you know what I mean
what does that say about us dude
yeah that's pretty trashy yeah that's uh
uh that ain't green that and uh do you
always hear stories of like someone
sneaking a stripper in or a hooker for
like their somebody just our uncle on
the way out or something yeah somebody
just did that which I don't no I'm not
thinking about that I don't want some
[__] skank in there why not I want
[__] father so and so
let me know that I'm good at that day
I'm not gonna get jammed up when I get
up there letting you know you better
bring your sunscreen because you're
going to hell now keep that real close
to the skin fat boy while you're burning
for eternity you're going to want to
reapply yeah I want everybody in there
the Monsignor nuns the whole nine yards
give me something I'm not thinking about
getting my noodle wet they're like a bad
accountant like I can't clean all this
up are you crazy you should have came to
me you should have at least filed that's
half the problem Jesus
yeah [__] that
I'm not thinking about that [__] how do
you know sitting there with a chubby no
meanwhile you got a priest [__]
eyeing you up all right trying to
[__] snap one off real quick no you'd
be all shriveled up you don't know I I
know how fear Works in me
what I know how I know when I'm afraid
I'm not but you've never truly been
afraid for your life sure I have
no you're afraid you left the stove on
or you know you called somebody by
accident did I
either way what a 48 minute voicemail I
don't want some chick from [__]
Delilah's in there I think I think
you're looking at this that's why I
think you're looking at this very
narrow-minded I don't want it either but
I'm saying I can see a world
where if I'm like hey I'm on my way out
it's been
a while yeah let me clean the pipes you
know what I mean
at least why show up to heaven with my
head on straight not acting like a fool
as soon as I get there that's what I'm
saying you know what I mean hitting on
every Broad in line Maryland
oh God here comes Skippy
like a rabid dog running around running
around St Peter's
um all right uh this one's from Xavier
is it garbage if the barbecue place in
your town replace the old Funeral Home
[Music]
don't think I could eat there man I I
I'm not like a big I guess I kind of am
a big heebie-jeebies guy but that's just
weird to me nah I can't do it the ribs
are to die for yeah and then also like
they think they got the same smoker the
same Broiler or whatever that they cook
the people in I don't know
those things get hot though it's the
same game
there's no way they're gutting a hole
those things are heavy
um there is a I called it I couldn't
I've talked to you guys about it it
would have to
I couldn't yeah no absolutely there's
there's an old Chinese place in China my
hometown that was like then it was like
it was a like a sit-down Chinese spot
which I've always said are the best
rolling in there on a Friday night oh
man real classy place real nice closed
down they're turning into like some kind
of Elementary School whoa get the [__]
out of here one of those like Charter
type things something like that private
school but like yeah those like
yeah whatever it is right there the
funeral home
into a barbecue joint that's nuts I
don't even like going to something that
used to be a Wawa no you know what I
mean no I don't like that or something
that used to be a bank or something I'm
like I this was a Wendy's and now it's a
bank at least about one by Aster place
there was clearly a Wendy's and now it's
a Chase Bank yeah I'm in there
salivating trying to [__] trying to
get my check cleared no I don't like it
I don't like it they tried to turn a
Burger King into a dry cleaners that
didn't work
I guess the drive-through is there
though that's probably pretty good who
does drive through Dry Cleaning ours had
it growing up really yeah you'd pass it
through the window wouldn't everything
get wrinkled getting it through the
window I think they would open up your
back door like if it was hanging on the
back like hanging on the hook
you pull up to a window and there was
like a sliding glass door really maybe
there's only this one I don't know wait
a minute wait a minute hold on it wasn't
it wasn't like a drive-through window it
was a whole thing
because that's pretty cool yeah it was a
sliding glass door and they would just
open your back door and put it on the
hook yeah or like take it off the hook
they open up the door you're there
they [__] pull it off like okay what
do you got three suits okay whatever
whatever here's your ticket you're gone
that's all right pick it up open up the
back door hang it up there have a nice
day Zip Zap Zoop that's all right is
that not a thing I've never heard of
anything like that in my life really and
we're Big Dry Cleaning shout out to
Earls he was at The Cutting Edge of it
wow did you hear that
and you're sitting there in silence
after hearing this goddamn that's
[__] real good but then my sister
worked there because the biggest pain in
the ass is getting it on that hook in
the back seat
sure Jamie up that's like one of those
CIA Skyhook drops where they scoop the
guy off the ground yeah like they didn't
Batman Begins yup I keep getting those
uh tick tocks or Instagram videos of the
Train the delivery system the mail the
mailman on the train you ever see that
and like remote towns or whatever like
they don't stop the train but there's a
mailman on the train who delivers to
each town and they have there's like a
big pole that they gotta hook the
outgoing mail like they all the town
gathers their mail and puts it in a like
one of those like canvas bags that's
like locked and it's hanging on a thing
and a guy comes up with a hook Scoops it
and leaves the same like leaves one he's
got a he's gotta hook the bag of the
incoming mail and grab the outgoing mail
really and I am all about it because I
like the videos it is it is mail
delivery at its highest form I like the
videos of the boats coming by the dock
and they have some green horn jumpers
yes very similar grab the man who's got
to get back on sometimes they don't make
it yeah it's a good time
yeah no that's I'm a big fan of that too
yeah man that's that's got to be
exhilarating that's got to be scary see
the guys getting on the uh
on the ships and like the Antarctic
where they're like on ice and the ship
comes by and they and they and they get
on and off real quick I don't think so
but as a kid who grew up
on boats in you know like [__]
pontoon boats or small crab boats or
fishing boats in Wildwood and like the
Poconos yeah I'm talking about oil
tankers in Antarctic yeah I understand
right UK lose the two guy who's never
been on a boat before not you catching
sunnies I'm I'm relating to the story
that you just told go ahead you
swashbuckler tell us the tales of this
no as a young kid that was the coolest
thing you felt like you were a one of
those guys when you're pulling up to the
dock and you're like I'm gonna I get to
jump off or grab the thing like can you
do that can you jump off and and do like
the the lasso around the uh around the I
mean you don't last away if your jump
ball you don't have to throw it you just
jump off with it and [__] tie it up
yeah [__] my knots aren't good but
I'll get it on there and then someone
had to come take you know re-double knot
it I was I was putting a windsor knot on
it
working the forehead Bandit yeah
um but that was exhilarating as a kid of
like all right I'm gonna and I never
like when I got to do it were they'd be
like Kevin yeah it's like the [__]
whole world's on your shoulder like
you're gonna sink if you don't [__]
get up there and get the bumper out you
know what I mean
oh my dumbass almost got hit by a
propeller one time
we weren't docking but we were we were
they were slowing down for the kids to
jump off I must have been like 11. and
my dumb ass jumped straight off the
front of the boat and got instantly Run
Over By the way Jesus Christ really dude
it was all good life jacket scoot me
right off the side chilling that gives
me anxiety we were in uh
we were in Lakewood I wouldn't get it
until it was completely turned off yeah
cause you're no fun if that propeller
catches you
my bad dude my buddy's dad was like holy
[__] yeah
uh and Blake wall and Paul pack the prop
fell the prop fell off our boat like the
[__] hand like the bobby pin hinge or
whatever like broke or something so then
we're [__] we're we're rudderless we
got nothing but luckily it happened at
the dock I think they might have been
fixing or changing it or something and
it happened at the dock he went down
there and got it I mean we did that was
our job the whole weekend that was like
we felt like deep sea divers that was
like forget fishing forget all kids of
Honor forget a wave runner forget it
forget a bonfire dude we were [__] I
was I don't got a knife in my mouth I
was going down ready to see an octopus I
was it was it man fighting a giant squid
oh dude I was he couldn't see [__] too
[__] trying to open my eyes in a lake
Kevin Ryan in four feet under the lake
people are just standing next to me
searching with their feet wow that was
big too searching with your feet not a
lake what in a lake yeah never I mean
yeah I don't buy Piggies aren't touching
that muck sure I don't even like the
beach with the sand you don't like
anything fun I'll lay drugs in a room
yeah I'm saying it's not ideal but it
happens drugs in a room it happens you
gotta you get Icky toes when you're out
there having a good time no I couldn't
agree with fully more dude good yeah I'm
not saying like I wasn't like reveling
in it but it happens man we my cousins
lived out I think it might have been
rocks too at the shore my cousin lived
out at Serene Lakes California which was
a beautiful Lake but would you say it's
Serene it was very Serene near Lake
Tahoe and we were out there swimming one
time and you swam through like a patch
of like Lake grass
oh yeah it's not great dude it was like
Medusa was [__] coming at you from
the depths yeah no bueno you just really
gotta go I just gotta get through this
because you start panicking you start
panicking more than more stuff you just
gotta go I'm just trudging through this
[__] that freak me out yeah first time I
went to a Costco was out there too
biggest muffins I ever seen in my life
and those big four packs of muffins they
give you at Costco no never was never a
Costco guy we were a Sam's Club for a
sting short term but I mean I might have
been there two or three times sure that
was like that was like getting into
[__]
the White House for us Lee like had to
call my stepdad who had the thing oh
thank you oh yeah patty patty uh
used her uh use false credentials for
for I think a couple of years at Costco
and Sam's Club yeah
anybody asked my name's Colleen hola
como estas
La muffins
the refried beans please
uh uh speaking of this is a from Amanda
what's the trashiest Clash trip you
fellas ever been on mine was fourth
grade we went to Wegmans what the [__]
which foreign if you're not aware
Wegmans is a fancy grocery store though
yo kids get in here I got a big order
[Laughter]
yeah it's just some teacher who was lazy
yeah uh doing yard work at her summer
house that's uh that ain't that's a I
mean what do you do maybe I guess you
gotta go for like you got to be learning
the thing was they were always learning
about something you know what I mean I
wasn't the AP classes I could tell you
that no I think that was taking taking a
tour of the loading dock
learning to be a single man in his
mid-30s [__] settling weed out of the
deli
and this is where I rip heaters on my
break
one of you kids got a light
ah uh yeah
I I remember my boy worked for a long
time uh in the meat department at a at
an Acme okay uh Quality quality
operation quality operation uh it was
before he found his career you know
before he found his career or whatever
uh and he was working there and he was
like dude it made it it seemed real nice
because he's like we go every day meat
department had a crock pot there so he
goes we'd go in if I was working like an
eight nine hour shift or whatever I'm
listening beginning of the shift to
crank up the crock pot whatever they had
you know whatever was laying around sure
uh this filet got stepped on or whatever
chop that up [__] throw it in come
three four five hours later they're all
back there just [__] Cup going to
town and I was like I genuinely envy you
that is amazing all time work make work
better moves yeah sure yeah little work
side hustle uh-huh that's huge that and
our our uh
that and who the [__] I think it was big
bride from Jersey our boy big Bry from
Jersey yep which I've seen in other
times microwave on the work on the work
truck
you nuke whatever you want your work
he's he you know he works construction
so he's out there on the roads and [__]
like that nuke it up and I was like God
I've seen that one or two other times
very smart you know there's some guy in
some office jogging office job in the
middle of Ohio with a big green egg on
the roof dude smoking Meats oh yeah yeah
always in the cubicle sure I'm gonna
take a phone call be right back anytime
working at a restaurant that did like a
good family meal was always [__]
awesome and it was also Awesome every
once in a while like if it was slow and
it was a little bit later in the shift
and like a Thursday night the boys in
the kitchen would throw something
together sure something off the menu
I have the Gino's East I work at in
Chicago every now and again they bust
out some menudo that would knock your
socks off dude yeah it's all right
what's menudo it's like a popular 80s
band yes that's Ricky Martin wasn't he a
Menudo
uh I think he was right that was him
Ricky Martin was in menudo yeah uh I
remember these five dude Giuseppe's I
worked at Giuseppe's as a busboy and we
would get two slices of pizza or a salad
and a bowl of spaghetti or something
spaghetti it was what you know wasn't my
cup of tea I was more of a spaghetti
yeah but it was just not love pizza
place spaghetti you don't say yeah I
know it's very well documented perfectly
Al Dente in the sauce it's just the same
sauce from the pizza so it has a little
zest to it yeah no it just wasn't as
good yeah yeah it's fine it was fine it
was I'm not sure you're not really a
spaghetti guy nah I gotta be light on my
feet I'm working you're not a pasta guy
I am for sure are you
yeah but just like generic
pasta I don't know just like yeah a
couple [__] sleazies out the door in
a Wild Cherry Pepsi what the [__] are we
talking about here okay I'm a [__]
fat 10 year old all right
sign says Pizza dude yeah give me the
I'm not saying I'm sure you're very well
yes I'm sure there's pasta it's good I'm
[__] slice man throwing through okay
so you skipped the salad Porky yeah
never once did I get it I was like get
the [__] out of salad yikes I used to
make them they were like the house I
like hey we need three house salads for
whatever and it was my job and I'm like
dude
Iceberg and one Olive yeah that's what
it was like when you're [__] two
shoestring [__] pieces of carrot or
whatever
um
man those two slices of pizza I still
think of like they were the after a hard
shift you sit down all these [__] all
these [__] these broads are counting
their tip money cranking heaters in the
back ah you couldn't tell me [__] two
big triangle slices [__] good A
little bit of a rug I know maybe some
Parmesan sitting on a bus pan [__]
put me out dude it was great some of my
best slices in the world were there
perfect they've been sitting around for
a little while they throw them I'll do
my two you live quite the life Kippy
I'll tell you that uh like a regular J
Peterman
quite the Tails my friend yeah fat kids
like pizza you know I don't know what to
tell you
um
all right let's see this one's from Pure
garbaggio uh ten dollar hamie is it
garbage to have a hot tub on the ground
floor of your split level home on the
carpeted floor whoa I've seen this one
other time it's Coke you're moving a
week
and we talking yeah you got to be moving
some heavy weight well there's
this is I've seen this one time before
living room
ground floor this was basement it was
one of those like the house was built on
a hill so the whole back of the house
was exposed you know what I mean
okay you could walk out the basement but
this guy I'm imagining it's it's like an
in-ground pool it's not on the floor
it's in the floor no that's what this
guy's talking about no this is a hot tub
on the ground floor so it's a hot tub
on the first floor of the house okay not
in the floor it's in the floor I think
that's a little classier
hot tubs don't belong inside no jacuzzis
do hot tubs belong outside
jacuzzis yeah what's the difference
a hot tub stays full you don't fill a
hot tub
okay
you fill a Jacuzzi no you mean like a
jacuzzi tub yeah but your mom probably
has like what used to yeah yeah because
when I redid all those houses all the
broads all got those big jacuzzis yeah
that was the first time I saw a shower
and a bathtub separate
when my aunts and my aunt Uncle redid
their bathroom uh-huh blew me away I
didn't know where to pee huh
where do I go the whole neighborhood was
over there what do you got TiVo can I
blow your mind sure okay hot tub is the
name we use to describe a tub filled
with hot water for people to relax in
jacuzzi is a brand oh no I know that I
didn't know that really yeah [__]
but a hot tub in the house so you're
wrong
no not at all yeah why is jacuzzi on the
inside
you said a hot tub was for outside
jacuzzi was for inside here's my this is
my rule I'm saying I don't think you
should just have a hot tub full with
water with that lid on it constantly
cooking in your house which was what my
friend used to have which was insane
okay it sounds like you're it's a fog up
the windows yeah it smells like the
[__] YMCA in there sure that's what
I'm saying you should yeah not to live
in you should drain anything you're
doing in the house should be drained
you gotta fill back up yeah that's what
you should do there shouldn't be
chlorine in your house right can you
will you give me that I'll give you that
there shouldn't you shouldn't have a
body of water with chemicals constantly
102 degrees in your house that's insane
to me I'll give you that that belongs
Outdoors okay
jacuzzi yeah jacuzzi is a brand name
all all jacuzzis are hot tubs but not
all hot tubs are jacuzzis dude there you
go there you go
it's pretty good look at this we're
learning today yeah we really are uh all
right yes that's trash
the mold and the carpet alone yeah the
smell the steam man God damn that house
has a drop ceiling for sure sure and it
is brown dude oh yeah a couple of water
water stains on there and also what did
you want it outside I guess the
temperature like
because you would want to be cooler so I
guess it would have to be in some type
of bathroom setting in the living room
that's what I'm saying my buddy had it
in the base if I blew my mind I was like
what are you guys shooting porn in here
this is [__] nuts was it a finished
basement yeah was there a there's a
computer right next to it was there a uh
sliding glass door to get outside down
there
yeah but not right there not near it on
the other side huh
what about a cold plunge indoors in a
basement of course it's the way to go
yeah I'll give you that I'd give you
that love to have that that's a little
different no chlorine again and no Steam
and functional
very true huh yeah I don't
a body of water in the house that's just
constantly full I want to get one for
the roof but I don't know if it'll hold
that'd be a jam up you end up on the
fifth floor how you doing I'm I'm Henry
I live upstairs
is this your girl
how long he's been together
what are you watching John Wick though
is that pasta from a pizza place yeah
all right gentlemen
uh all right this one's from Sean uh
uh is it garbage to have a negative
balance on cash app my buddy has a
negative 300 balance how do you get that
it sounds like you got away with
something yeah I've been Jam I think
those things process if you have if
you're using it as a payment
and I'm sure some sort of bank there's
some sort of delay these dirtbags are
figuring out uh-huh as one who used to
do it sure you know I know my way around
to banking day sure processing there's
got to be something that's hooked up to
that that automatically chart or
something I used to roll that die oh
it's one of my favorite things you want
to live a little TD Bank still got the
pinkertons looking for me for that one
I should be on the 310 to Yuma Wells
Fargo coming after you you can buy
stocks on the cash app
really yeah which if you got a cash app
portfolio that thing is
I'll tell you that's where you're
playing the market T-Bone
got it all in Mountain Dew I got 1 100th
of a share of Pizza Hut
uh I'm making decisions in the boardroom
and the better they're all pushing that
uh the flipped over pizza now the what's
it called
pizzon need kind of it's a calzones yeah
but it's crispy it's like it's it's like
a slice flipped over they're all pushing
it I think uh Papa John's kicked it off
first the papadia papadia whoa I gotta
get eyes on it oh one shot got in there
he really started making some changes
hey everything he should be on Shark
Tank everything he touched I think he
has gold has he uh I know Charles
Barkley has what's he doing
that dude's caked out from the way stop
that yeah Charles bark that's all Shaq
money from TNT what's Charles invested
in dude those dudes are like crazy I
know shotgun's Forever 21 I heard I dude
Shaq kills it uh Shaq has never been on
Shark Tank but he has been in a shark
cage on Shark Week
it's close enough
I mean that counts that shark was that
that shark was [__] in his pants
I'll tell you that was that in Egypt
where was that
um all right let's do uh let's do one
more here then we gotta wrapper up
gaming this one's from Daryl ten dollar
investor is it garbage to have people in
your family who refer to who are
referred to as big and little instead of
senior and Junior such as big Terry and
little terry or big Jenny and Little Jim
big Jenny stuff big Jenny will [__] you
up
yeah I have we have big Mike and little
Mike big Jenny makes a mean Hoagie dip
though I'll tell you that she does
something that knocks everybody's socks
off every Thanksgiving and I'll tell you
that you got a bit of a tube to her oh
yeah use your thumb yeah they're calling
people [__] I call them the kids
yeah little [__] you know who wears
a one-piece suit big Jenny oh big Jenny
can rock the can rock the jumper oh yeah
yeah or some Carhartt overalls sure uh
yeah we got Big Mike little Mike and Big
Mike it's like you know it's like out of
a [__]
but you know little Mike is a [__]
house yeah Big Mike little Mike is now
Big Mike yeah yeah uh okay this is from
Chris uh Philly Bozo here shout out to
it uh is it garbage to jump in the
swimming pool instead of taking a shower
after a haircut gets all the hair off
you and you get a little exercise in as
well
Ah that's a pro move though because I
feel like the shower
if you submerge I need full shower after
a haircut I need full shower I need hair
wash ears washed the whole nine yards
otherwise I'm itching up and down the
block plus you're getting all that
goddamn hair in the filter I think
Patty's gonna come yelling at you for
that
they're fine you've ever found a frog in
that filter all the time man I used to
scare the [__] out of you open that up
that [__] thing's staring at you it's
a pair of sunglasses on
ripping a heater yeah
oh my daddy to come get him let's go and
your piss tastes weird buddy check that
out
frogs in the pool shout out to him all
right we gotta wrap it up gang gang we
love you to death and we will see you
next week